voilà un nom mais lui ça fait tout de
suite beau gosse moi ça fait dégueulasse
imagine si besoin de laurent delahousse
était ce un bon soir à 12 lors les
titres du journal
[Applaudissements]
et regardez qui nous a rejoint thierry
moreau et oui on s'est croisés sur tp ne
fait pas longtemps on s'est croisé n'a
pas été longtemps sans que j'en ai même
plateau vous êtes parti en 2010 est
absolument le mois de mai 2010 2 buts
début de mai 2010 est un petit mot pour
caractériser ces lingots un seul mot fou
mais au sens sympa du terme fou faut
pour tous les sens en dehors de en vue
lors de la de la planète ça il est voilà
c'est pas il est pas comme nous comment
ça va depuis que vous avez quitté pmp ça
va très bien j'ai conduit télé 7 jours
pendant deux ans après le départ de tpm
fait oui maintenant j'ai créé une
société où je fais du conseil et puis je
m'amuse aussi sur twitter ça c'est la
grande mode tout le monde
tout le monde fait du tout c'est très
très très en amont sur sa des lives en
fait le mardi le jeudi de 11 heures à 13
heures et puis le dimanche on fait un
début de la semaine on parle côté télé
mais pas que mais pas que ce qu'en fait
toute l'actualité passe par le prisme de
la télévision ou des médias donc on peut
parler de tout au travers des médias
c'est ça qui est bien et puis on a une
grande liberté sur tweak qui me rappelle
un peu la liberté qu'on était pembe sur
tp il va d'un éventuel will be 3 4 ans
oui c'est pas un petit mot qui
caractérise votre patron votre pas trop
incontrôlable
c'est pas mal ça voilà contrôlable il
faut c'est la vérité il faut quand même
dire aujourd'hui n'en garde que le
nombre de fois où on commence une
émission avec on a travaillé toute la
journée on a préparé le conducteur on
c'est sûr qu'on a bossé le nombre de
fois allez je vais pas vous mentir ces
trois fois sur cinq ou au moment où
commencent les missions tout change dans
sa tête et personne est au courant je
n'ai jamais vu ça pour nous aussi avons
bossé à tf1 où tout est calibré tout est
fait pour nous pas pour moi au début
c'était un extraterrestre c'est un peu
ça c'est impossible
il a cassé tous les codes de la télé